hello everyone and welcome to round 10
of the 2021 tata steel chess tournament
we have a a very top tier game between
world number one and world number two
magnus carlsen versus fabiano corona uh
caruana has the white pieces
and he is currently leading the
tournament in a joint lead
and magnus is trailing uh by a point so
he of course would very much enjoy
beating
fabiano corona but uh fabi playing with
the white pieces uh that's uh
not not an easy win definitely for for
anyone in the world
so can magnus do it or will fabi even
further his lead in the tournament let's
see what happened in this game so fabi
uh with the white pieces opened with d4
sorry about that we have knight to f6 by
magnus
uh c4 uh and now e6 we have g3
fabiops40 catalan opening we have d5 and
now
knight to f3 we have bishop to be for
check and now bishop to d2 so
this is all very standard stuff bishop
back to d6 and now
bishop to g2 we have c6 nicely
strengthening the position in the center
knight to c3 and now magnus castles and
here
bishop to g5 black wasted a tempo
bringing the dish back to d6 and so
white will also waste one
getting it from d2 to g5 uh with h6
magnus pushes the bishop back and now we
have a trait here
captures captures and this is uh the
position that fabi
definitely had in his home preparation
because this position has been reached
in top tier game many
games many times it's been reached in
being versus the pal of gate found
versus
versus giri uh bachmann versus kramnik
and so on
and the one of the most popular moves
here is castles but here uh fabi
prepares queen to b3
and queen to b3 is a new move in the
position uh so let's see what happens as
it it's a move tender we have a
completely new game
so he's going after the b7 pawn but
more often than not when uh you play
something like this that's never really
your
your goal so here you're also putting
additional pressure to the center
because now you can see all of these
pieces are attacking the center bishop
is x-raying the d5
square so very interesting okay for the
moment this is defended but it does uh
prevent black from developing freely so
knight to d7 by magnus and here
fabi castles with queen back to e7 by
magnus
and now comes c5 pushing the bishop back
we have bishop to c7
and now e4 striking in the center we
have b6
which is often what you want to do when
you have such a weird advancement of the
pawn
which is often uh characterized as an uh
you know another very positional idea
you want to challenge those pawns with
uh moves like b6
so b6 and here fabi trades once on d5 we
have e captures on the e5 e captures on
e5
and rook f2e1 now attacking carlson's
queen
and now carlson needs to figure out what
to do with the queen obviously you have
two choices either queen back to the
eight or queen to f6
and here magnus went queen to f6 which
allows fabi a very very interesting idea
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the rook on a8 is undefended and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
knight captures on the e5 and this comes
with an attack on the queen and the
bishop here
so you have to capture uh the knight we
have c captures on d5
and now queen captures on the e5
attacking the rook
and you might think okay so i just moved
the rook and what's the point of this
knight sacrifice the point is after rook
the b8 fabi pushed c6
and now carlson's knight is trapped here
on d7 so
very very uh a very nice preparation by
fabi here
and also you have to be careful if
somehow this queen moves and this pawn
gets
uh to d5 while being defended then
that's
just a terrible position so here fabi uh
magnus has no choice other than to give
up
the knight the knight has no squares all
of the squares that the knight can go to
are covered the rooks are blocking the
knight here and here
and here if you play uh there's there's
nothing you can play you have to
uh move the knight there's there or
rather you you
cannot move the knight you you have to
play something but there really isn't a
good movie you could try knight to c5
maybe to force a white to capture with
the pawn
but other than that you have rook to d8
this is what magnus played
and now fabi just grabs that knight on
d7 so
c captures on d7 bishop captures and
now knight to e5 by fabi this is maybe
perhaps one move where fabi could have
could have played a stronger move but
fabi had probably had this analyzed with
a
with a really really strong engine
because i only left the position to be
analyzed to the depth of
40 and the rook 8 to c1 is the only top
move that
the engine recommends here going after
that bishop on c7
and just developing the only undeveloped
piece uh
which seems to be still giving why the
advantage but fabi went knight to the e5
right away
and here magnus just uh plays bishop to
e6 the bishop is under attack he first
attacks the queen
and now he's going to eliminate this
knight on e5 we have queen back to e4
and the bishop captures on e5 we have d
captures
with an attack on the queen here and
queen back to e7 and now we have this
uh end game two rooks and the bishop for
each side and
fabi is up upon so can he make use of
that pawn
it's uh four against three on the king's
side so
uh very very hard to take advantage of
that maybe if it was two
against one on the queen side then it'd
be somewhat easier but again
very hard to do so here queen to e3 fabi
wants to centralize this bishop from
this e4 square the bishop will be a
monster piece
so here we have rook beat the c8 getting
the rook into the game
and bishop to e for now by fabi now
controlling a lot of squares uh
controlling the c2 square so magnus
doesn't have a very nice rook lift here
we have queen to c5 now offering a queen
trade and
fabi accepts we have captures captures
and now f4
creating a beautiful pawn chain here and
with this bishop
nicely guarding against uh sorry uh this
wasn't captured with the pawn it was
captured with the rook uh and
only now we have f4 so the pawn chain is
very nicely placed here and black might
have some ideas of bringing the rook
all the way down to d2 uh but also uh
you kind of have to worry about
f5 so magnus first needs to deal with
that he plays g6
and now king to f2 so now if the rook
comes down you you can easily trade one
one pair of rooks so here
a5 by magnus and king to e3 fabi
improves the position of the king
we have a4 by magnus and now rook eat
the c1
offering a trade of a pair of rooks we
have rook to b5
magnus needs to collect at least one
pawn to equalize
uh we have rook to c2 now defending the
spawn and now
rook to b4 uh putting putting uh uh
pressure on this bishop here and this
also comes with a trick
because here if bobby isn't careful if
he plays something like a3 then magnus
can just
play rook captures on e4 captures and
bishop checks and then
he he picks up the rook here on c2 so
after rook to b4 we have bishop back to
d3 fabio of course avoids such a tactic
and now magnus further grabs the space
on the king side with h5
we have rook to d2 by fabi and now b5
we have a3 charging the rook here and
rook to b3 now
so magnus definitely has some pressure
here and fabi needs to be very careful
uh and here fabi goes rook to c1 he
wants to bring the rook over to
the c7 uh or he wants to activate his
rook a little bit
also rook the c3 is an idea just uh get
rid of
one pair of rooks but here magnus finds
a very interesting move and it's the
only move that uh
sort of uh takes away any advantage from
fabi so once again feel free to pause
the video and try to find
this only move in the position while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting
my favorite move in the uh entire game
of chess and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's b4 uh my favorite is usually b4
when white plays it but okay
we'll we'll go with this guy here so
this works because
uh well before i show you why it works
first i'm going to show you a very
interesting line for example
rook d captures on d3 if you sacrifice
the exchange here
to pick up the pawn it looks very
interesting you still have the very
strong
bishop now you have the two to one
advantage here so maybe it is possible
to do something about it but it's very
easy for white to just
parry all the all the threats just rook
the c7 and now
after bishop to c4 cutting off the rook
attacking this
rook you can go rook to d8 to check king
g7 and now just rook c to c8 and with
these pawns cutting of the king from
uh entering the game it's just not not
playable anymore uh
you cannot push any pawns or do anything
because this is just
check check and the other rook will
deliver mate and g8
so just wanted to mention that before we
go to b4 so this was magnus played
magnus played
b4 uh we have a captures on b4
and now a3 so what was the point of all
this b
for a3 idea the point is to take away
white's control of the c3
uh square because without this uh if you
just went
for example uh if you just played
something
uh let's say you went bishop to f5 you
want to add more attackers to the bishop
here just rook the c3 and the white
defense perfectly fine and he's still up
upon
so he has excellent winning chances here
so instead this is what magnus found and
once again congratulations to everyone
who found it as it's not an easy idea to
find
captures and a3 now finally takes away
the c3 square from white
b captures and a3 and only now bishop to
f5 and now this
move no longer exists so you have to
play rook to d1
but now magnus just collects on a3 rook
captures on a3
and it doesn't seem like there's much
for white to do here white is completely
tied down and
there are no good moves here uh fabi
played b5
as it's the only pretty much pawn push
you could do you you could also try h4
or something like that
but now magnus just goes bishop g4 uh
pushes the rogue back we have rooked the
c1
and now magnus secures uh the
draw with bishop to f5 again a triple
attack on the bishop here the bishop
cannot move because of this
check so fabi is forced to repeat rook
d1
uh bishop to g for rook to c1 bishop to
f5
rook c to d1 and it was in this position
that
uh fabian magnus agreed to a draw on
move 42
after reaching time control so very very
uh very very top top level game and uh
like i said
it was uh around this point where after
this bishop captures and d7 that i could
spot
pretty much the only instance where fabi
maybe could have played a stronger move
for example this rook a to c1 instead of
allowing magnus to
simplify immediately but i guess you
don't uh
expect uh uh you know for the side that
has um uh that's down upon that
simplifying
will be will be useful for that side but
here it worked out pretty well
especially since magnus founded this
beautiful uh
idea where he just gave up the pawns
like
here with the
uh sorry i mean i'm in the wrong wrong
bracket
uh here this b4 uh idea and after
capturing this
just freed the c3 square and he was able
to secure a very quick draw
so very very interesting stuff and uh
it's always a clash b when a fabian
magnus meet because they're
number one and number two in the world
and they played the uh
entire world chess championship match so
the entire 10 games of classical chess
without a single win so they drew all 10
games so
again it's uh still still a draw between
the two of them
and we'll see we'll see what happens in
the next one but yeah
usually when they meet i will always
show the game because i mean if we don't
show a game where
number one and number two play then what
are we really doing
uh sure that's uh the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
magnus can't be very happy with the
result but
then again uh maybe he can't be happy
with the result in the tournament
situation currently but a draw against
fabi with the black pieces any any man
would be perfectly fine with that
whereas for fabi who is currently
leading the tournament a draw against
magnus is
is uh more than welcome so i will see
what happens uh
st the tournament is still young so the
same so uh you know
anything is still happen so once again
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank kyle uli ricardo lima brandon
kirk panova pianza and peter harley for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata still 2021 checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day